[Musique]
bonjour frédéric leicester flac un jour
on va revenir sur ses choix tragique des
médecins face à la pénurie de ressources
à l'hôpital mais d'abord cette question
personnelle qu'est l'étrange situation
pour vous la chercheuse l'universitaire
qui travaillaient sur ces sujets c4
conscience depuis longtemps qu'avez-vous
ressenti au fond quand cette forme de
cauchemar est devenu réalité oui c'est
exactement ça c'est mon cauchemar
personnel ma névrose personnel qui
devient partagé par tout le monde et ça
fait très bizarre on est quelques-uns à
travailler sur ces questions de deux
choix d'arbitrage de triage qu'est ce
qu'on fait quand on peut pas sauver tout
le monde a qui vont les ressources trop
rares pour être distribuée à l'ensemble
de la population et là d'un coup cette
situation non seulement elle devient
notre lot quotidien mais surtout elle
devient visible elle est posée sur la
place publique elle est débattue par
tout le monde et n'importe qui et là
évidemment les choses de tout à fait
différent jusqu'à présent c'étaient des
questions dont personne ne voulait
entendre parler ou alors dont on sent
paraît avec disons le le plaisir du
sensationnalisme morale et la
maintenance et des questions auxquelles
on peut plus lui échapper alors il ya
des mots comme ça qui nous assaillent
par ce qu'ils renvoient de presque
d'épouvantables on parle de pénurie on
parle de réquisition on parle aussi de
rationnement et puis il ya ce mot de tri
de triage entre les vies entre les
malades vous allez nous dire de quoi il
s'agit précisément mais d'abord à quoi
il nous renvoie qu'est-ce qu'ils
réveillent en nous ce mot de tri alors
ce tri il est très problématique parce
que ce terrain de tri réveillent des
démons du réveil des anciens spectre
trier entre lévis apparaît à tout le
monde une abomination sa part est le
comble de l'horreur moral on devrait pas
avoir à choisir les sacrifiés et il ya
tout un imaginaire commun un imaginaire
partagée de ses choix tragique où il
faut choisir qui on sacrifie et à qui on
accorde une chance de survie moi j'ai
étudié ces situations dans des contextes
historiques réels par exemple pendant la
deuxième un mondial dans les camps nazis
dans des situations de deux génocides ou
il s'agissait d'exfiltrer une partie de
la population pour ne pas se retrouver
face à la destruction générale dans des
contextes historiques réels
ces procédures ou ces protocoles
sacrificielle projet évidemment des
ombres désastreuse alors aujourd'hui
quand on parle de tri on parle pas
exactement de la même chose bien sûr
alors de quoi s'agit-il à l'hôpital
précisément ce qu'on appelle le tri dans
en urgence médicale collective se sont
ainsi d'un ensemble de procédés qui
consiste à pouvoir orchestrer des ordres
de priorité dans la prise en charge des
malades dans la prise en charge des
patients il faut préciser que ça a été
inventé sur le champ de bataille
napoléonien c'est l'arrêt le chirurgien
de napoléon qui a proposé cette idée de
trier les blessés non pas en fonction de
leur grade c'est pas les officiers
d'abord et les simples soldats seulement
s'il vous reste des ressources fossiles
en fonction de la gravité et de leurs
pronostics et donc sur un champ de
bataille quand on peut pas soigner tout
le monde en même temps quand on peut pas
prendre en charge tous les blessés eh
bien on cherche à maximiser le nombre de
vies sauvées et donc ça peut entraîner
des procédures où on ne peut pas
consacrer le temps et les ressources
nécessaires aux blessés les plus graves
qu'ils demanderaient à leur seul
bénéfice trop de temps et trop de
ressources déjà d'entrée de jeu
peut-être il faut le préciser ça ne
s'est pas produit ces situations de tri
à l'hôpital en france même pendant le
pic de l'épidémie il faut il faut
dissiper une ambiguïté du tri il y en a
tout le temps à l'hôpital et en
particulier les urgentistes les
réanimateurs pratiquer le tri couramment
parce que le tri pour eux ça signifie se
demander si le malade on le ramène
justifie une réanimation est ce que ça
fera sens de le réanimer ou est ce que
c'est une mauvaise décision c'est pas
toujours la bonne décision c'est pas
parce que c'est techniquement possible
qu'il faut le faire et qu'il est juste
de le faire donc du tri il y en a tout
le temps à l'hôpital il ya du tri sur
listes d'attentes quand vous arrivez aux
urgences en dehors d'eux
de pandémie c'est premier arrivé premier
servi vous pouvez attendre cinq heures
pour un poignet foulé parce qu'il ya des
cas plus graves qui passe d'abord donc
du tri y en a tout le temps on peut pas
dire qu'on n'a pas pratiquer le tri on
pratique le tri tout le temps en
revanche ce qui s'est passé en italie ce
sont des situations différentes c'est
choisir entre deux vies a situation
sauvable égal décrivez-nous ce qui s'est
passé en lombardie notamment ceux dont
on a entendu parler en lombardie c'est
des services hospitaliers saturé c'est à
dire que des services hospitaliers où on
peut pas prendre des nouveaux patients
et/ou du coup bien on peut pas étendre
le stock de ressources contrairement à
ce que nous on a réussi à faire à france
c'est-à-dire transférer des patients
dans d autres régions insaturés quand il
ya saturation et quand il ya plusieurs
patients qui arrivent avec un pronostic
médical équivalent comment est-ce qu'on
arbitre il faut pas laisser ça à
l'arbitraire des médecins en première
ligne il faut pas il faut appliquer des
règles qui soient justes qui tiennent
compte de l'écouté et c'est de là que le
les médecins italiens ont sorti un
document qui évidemment a causé un effet
de sidération mais un document d' de
recommandation il ya eu des critères qui
ont été posées et qui ont été appliqués
lesquels et avec quelle légitimité au
nom de quoi on peut décider que tel ou
tel critère est préférable à un autre
alors l'idée générale c'est l'équité et
la maximisation du bénéfice collectif
c'est à dire sauver le plus de vies
possibles sauver le plus de vies
possible ça signifie ne pas utiliser
dans un usage compassionnel des
ressources dont on est presque sûr
qu'elles ne serviront pas ça veut dire
quelqu'un qui a une très faible chance
de survivre à la réanimation on n'essaie
même pas et la difficulté pour la
perception publique de ce problème c'est
que l'un des des facteurs de mauvais
pronostic
l'un des facteurs qui qui fait que vous
allez avoir peu de chances de survivre à
la réanimation c'est l'âge et c'est ce
qui a été très visible évidemment
lombardie on en a beaucoup parlé chez
nous aussi et ça peut se produire dans
d'autres contextes
l'âge est un facteur de très mauvais
pronostic c'est à dire qu'une personne
âgée peu à peu de chance de bien
supporter de supporter tout court la
réanimation et les semaines et les mois
après la réanimation de rééducation vous
pensez que c'est à la société de
s'emparer de ces sujets là qu'au fond il
y à une sorte de débat démocratique à
avoir sur sur ces critères là oui bien
sûr qu'il ya un débat démocratique à
avoir il est extrêmement compliqué il
est extrêmement coûteux pour la cohésion
nationale c'est très difficile de
demander aux gens même en dehors de la
crise
comment est ce que la société doit
penser sont finalement son son protocole
sacrificielle un key qui a priorité pour
vivre quand tout le monde ne peut pas
vivre mais quelle forme pourrait avoir
ce débat une consultation des citoyens à
débat à l'assemblée nationale il ya
toutes sortes de manières de faire on
peut
aux états unis ça fait des années qu'on
se prépare à la catastrophe en lançant
des exercices de public and get your man
sur ces sujets là donc c'est des
sondages qualitatifs ont ont fait jouer
aux
citoyens le rôle de médecin trieurs on
leur décrit des cas il ya trois patients
qui arrivent en même temps ou d'urgence
et il reste plus qu'un lit à qui vous
l'accordé en fonction des détails qu'on
vous donne à mon avis ce sont pas de
bonnes manières de faire parce que quand
vous donnez un certain nombre de détails
sur des patients qui arrivent en même
temps aux urgences ah et bien les
détails que vous donnez vous considérez
d'emblée qu'ils doivent avoir de
l'importance donc si vous donnez le
métier vous considérez que l'utilité
sociale doit avoir un rôle ce qui est
pas du tout le consensus aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui tous les documents sur le
tri exclu l'utilité sociale comme un
critère valable l'autre grand sujet qui
interpelle à la fois notre moral et puis
au fond la conscience collective c'est
cesser ce choix qu'ont fait pratiquement
tous les pays le choix de sauver des
vies au détriment finalement de la casse
sociale la crise économique qui suivra
forcément comment vous analysé ce choix
là qu'est ce que ça dit de notre société
est ce que la valeur de la lui-même a
considérablement augmenté
je ne sais pas si la valeur de la vie
humaine a augmenté ou si le passage à la
puissance tragique de ces sujets a
balayé toute possibilité d'une réflexion
pour bénéfices elle a pu avoir lieu
ailleurs que chez nous chez nous assez
peu il me semble que dans le risque
d'une saturation des services de santé
des hôpitaux il y avait comme une comme
une vision d'horreur morale qui était
tellement insupportable que on était
prêt à tout prix pour l'empêcher pour
empêcher d'en arriver là maintenant il
reste que les arbitrages sur le
déconfinement par exemple les arbitrages
sur remettre le pays en marche ou bien
s'épargner
encore des afflux de patients et donc
d'aider des morts supplémentaires
ces débats suppose d'avoir des unités de
mesure commune et en économie de la
santé comme en éthique médicale dans
certaines traditions d'éthique
médicale on a des instruments pour
mesurer ses coûts bénéfices qu on peut
calculer par exemple l'angleterre le
fait couramment depuis dans le cadre de
son système de santé on peut mesurer des
années de vie qualitatif sauver et donc
on peut tout faire rentrer dans un même
programme de mesures pour se demander
comment arbitrer mais vous
personnellement d'un point de vue moral
vous pensez que privilégier la vie
humaine sur l'économie c'est la première
fois que ça se fait à une aussi grande
échelle dans dans d'aussi nombreux états
en cas d'épidémie dans l'histoire des
pandémies c'est un progrès pour le dire
autrement est ce que la vie de milliers
d'hommes sauver valent plus au fond que
celle de ceux qui demain se retrouveront
sur la paille ce qui est intéressant
c'est que c'est c'est
l'egypte qui risquait d'être le plus
perdu dans ce contexte de pandémie c'est
lé vie de personnes âgées ou de
personnes fragiles et à aucun moment on
a fait un choix de société qui aurait
consisté à dire tant pis pour eux en pis
pour les personnes âgées au contraire on
est sur un modèle de société qui insiste
sur le fait qu'on ne veut pas sacrifier
nos aînés qu'on veut pas sacrifier deux
personnes âgées qu'on veut pas sacrifier
nos personnes fragiles et ce choix de
société qu'on a fait eh bien je crois
que c'est aussi quand même une raison
d'une raison d'être fiers une toute
dernière question dans ce monde après le
jour d'après on vous arrange de quel
côté des pessimistes ou des optimistes
plutôt des optimistes en revanche sur
cette question du tri dont on vient de
parler il me semble qu'on en aura pas
fini et maintenant que la question du
tri de la priorisation est devenue une
question public maintenant gala qu'elle
est sortie du bois qu'elle est sortie du
huis clos médicale on va pas s'en
débarrasser comme ça donc le tree hill
et pour longtemps avec nous on va devoir
se poser la question de savoir si
d'abord du dimensionnement notre système
de santé de la préparation à des
hypothèses catastrophique et pour le
dire très concrètement se poser la
question de savoir si c'est pas
nécessaire de garder des lits vides par
exemple pour ne pas avoir à faire
attendre trop longtemps les gens donc
cette question du rationnement des soins
que la pénurie extrême de catastrophes a
misé sur le devant de la scène peut-être
que on va l'aborder différemment et
peut-être que le débat public va pouvoir
exiger
que ce rationnement ce ne ne soit plus
pratique comme il l'était c'est à dire
de manière invisible et non discutée
merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]